[Music]
George Mallory dreamed of being the
first man to climb Everest he and his
fellow climber were last seen 800 feet
below the summit they were never seen
alive again 75 years after Mallory
vanished Mountaineer Conrad Anker took
part in an expedition looking for their
bodies this is George Mallory oh my god
[Music]
I'm going to have this chance to go back
and see what it was like for Mallory to
try climbing Everest in 1924
George Mallory and I are two paths have
intersected 75 years apart I know what
it's like to be the wife of a climber
who doesn't come home
My dear one I will be thinking of you as
you settle for the summit humans weren't
meant to survive this altitude suddenly
temperatures plummet to 20 below
freezing
there's no dream that mustn't be dead
[Music]
you